je m'appelle Charlette je suis très
jeune puisque je n'ai que 90 ans
théorie comment ça c'est le poste de
pilotage où il y a beaucoup de choses
mais quand je dois piloter c'est très
simple c'est une planche et un tréteaux
qu'on enlève et j'ai accès aux postes de
pilotage il y a aucun problème un bâton
d'une quinzaine de mètres on peut entre
700 et 800 euros par mois mais en étant
plein Paris on peut pas se plaindre j'ai
plus de 3000 livres sur le bateau donc
là c'est ce qu'on appelle la cabine
c'est la cabine la cabine de nuit c'est
ma chambre en fait j'ai un cabinet
toilette bon j'ai ma douche pas de
problème on vit normalement il y a du
désordre parce que comme je suis seul
personne ne peut me dire c'est pas rangé
c'est une cuisine frigidaire machine à
laver congélateur il y a tout tout
résumer ta vie sur un bateau qu'est-ce
que c'est je te dis moi c'est
c'est avoir trouvé le paradis sur terre
vivre sur un bateau